what's humming doing just a small
warning certain scenes do trigger
certain emotions it's really not anyone
else's business to tell someone when
they are mentally and emotionally ready
to deal with things if you create a sort
of a sense of a duty or for a professor
not to say anything that potentially
could trigger an emotional response from
students
you are really severely limiting the
world in which a professor can teach
have you ever been shocked by a violence
or disturbing scene in a movie book or
on the internet maybe you could have
used a trigger so a trigger warning
warranty about content you might be
facing that could provoke a response
based on some times of PTSD the concept
of the trigger warning first gained
popularity among feminists and social
justice blogs some of which include
extensive lists of possible triggers
ranging from depictions of rape and
abuse and war two needles and snakes and
small holes one site even lists
potential triggers and films such as
American Psycho which contains gore
murder and sexual violence against women
or it takes two which alludes to the
death of a parent
child abuse and child labor a few
enterprising college students are now
pushing to bring trigger warnings to the
classroom I was in a classroom was a
very small intimate classroom and we
were watching a film and there were
several scenes of sexual assaults and
finally a very drawn-out rape scene it
did not trigger me I recognized the
potential for it to be very triggering
Bayley lovren is a student at the
University of California Santa Barbara
and while Oberlin has attracted a fair
amount of media attention with its
wide-ranging list of triggers that
encompass racism colonialism religious
persecution violence suicide and more
it's actually love rands more focused
UCSB initiative that's gotten the most
traction passing the Student Assembly
and soon to be implemented as a mandate
for all professors I don't feel like
it's a problem asking for this to be
mandated that this should be an official
policy you're always gonna have someone
and it's gonna argue why this is this is
ridiculous I shouldn't have to do this
because I don't feel it why should
anyone else well the majority people are
already willing and actually
implementing this in classrooms this
reaches out to the people that have not
yet done so if universities had a
trigger warning saying if you want to go
to universities then be careful there
might be stuff that triggers you you
know that would be sort of absurd at
some level but ultimately if you're
going
the college that is a way of saying that
you're ready to talk about some really
serious issues being uncomfortable being
upset being even a little bit offended
is different than having a panic attack
blacking out hyperventilating screaming
in a classroom feeling like you're under
such physical threat whether it's really
perceived that you act out violently and
from other people the National Institute
of Mental Health estimates that about
three percent of the adult US population
suffers from post-traumatic stress
disorder the mental health network psych
central says that ordinary events can
serve as reminders of the trauma and
trigger flashbacks or intrusive images
that means almost anything in daily life
could be a potential trigger for someone
but Lovering has a plan for that the way
the resolution was written it directed
the office of student advocate which I'm
a part to consistently review and revise
this list with the assistance of the
Resource Center for gender and sexual
diversity the Women's Center and the
counseling psychological services on
campus I've been working defending
freedom of speech on college campuses
now for for thirteen years and the
problem with creating Sander that says
broad and vague as the one that they're
talking about at UCSB and the one they
already have at Oberlin is it very
quickly gets co-opted to limit
discussion and to punish people who have
points of view that you really strongly
disagree with how far can the trigger
argument be taken just a couple of weeks
after the resolution passed the Student
Assembly a women's studies professor
snatched a sign from some pro-life
protesters and then pushed one of them
away when she tried to take it back her
stated reason for doing so what she
argued was that the display was
triggering and it's an unfortunate part
of human nature if you give us a read of
an excuse to shut down speaking which we
disagree we're very quick to jump on
that you know we see it as an
opportunity